tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Gordon
goes head-to-head with the most stubborn
Chef he's ever met I thought your food
was crap that's a matter of opinion and
unearths the secret Garden's dirty
little
[Applause]
secrets Gordon Cooks up a rescue plan we
will make this a success but this French
chef fights back is everything perfect
in your kitchen I [__] dare start
lecturing me this is the lowest day of
this restaurant's life now can Gordon
Save The Secret Garden who the [__] are
you to turn around and tell me when you
were like a pig you French Pig find out
tonight on Kitchen
[Music]
Nightmares
more Park California gateway to Wine
Country luxury golf courses and booming
real estate a great location for our
restaurant but the secret garden is on
the brink of financial ruin thank you
for calling The Secret Garden how may I
help
you my name is Michelle I'm the chef and
owner at The Secret Garden am I a good
Chef I think so he's French that's his
biggest problem he's French so you got
have to excuse my
arrogance I'm not cooking with the stuff
that's in there when I lose my temper
it's time for you to run you told me
already earlier you were going to
compete and they have to leave Michelle
just may blow up and say what are you
doing you want to push me in the kitchen
I will scream at everybody Michelle's
arrogant his friend she's a chef all
chefs are arrogant you know what stop
repeating okay French people enjoy the
quality of life a little more than the
American I spill Michelle can be very
very uh difficult to work with Jane
Michelle that that cannot sit he's got
an ego the size of France as soon as
it's ready come on I let's fix it no no
no no no no I'm getting
frustrated the atmosphere here is
definitely geared toward a more mature
crowd this is the kind of restaurant
that you take your grandma out for a
nice
meal it's not really the happiness
Saturday night
spot Michelle is having a tough time
making in meet I can only imagine what
his books must look like we need
$200 that's not going to pay the bills
again I have about 300 to
$320,000 in thatb that's a lot of money
to pay back this is depressing look at
that if the restaurant keeps going the
way it's going I I won't be able to keep
the doors open I need
[Music]
help The Secret Garden fine
dining Gordon Ramsey has just one week
to uncover the problems to devise a plan
and to turn this restaurant
around place is
lck where's the
[Music]
entrance that's locked as
well
God I do
right
God bloody
[Music]
hell
God where is
everybody hello is anyone
[Music]
here who wants to sit and eat in front
of that fat little BS
Bard
morning hello how are you and you are
Jane Jane good to see you uh where's
Chef Chef's here okay Michelle good
morning welcome how are you Michelle how
are you yes nice to meet you good to see
you why I finally got in couldn't find
the front door the front door is off the
parking lot but I mean I couldn't find
it so it's the best kept secret in more
part and you've been running the
restroom for 7 years seven years yes God
and how long has it been quiet for 7
years okay well I'll go and sit in the
restaurant I feel like I'm at Buckingham
Palace um Jesus what is that that's a
it's it's uh doily people love those
people love those mhm ready you've got
all that fancy crap on there and yet the
glass is dirty oh God right it's almost
ready Jane I feel like inviting my
grandr for lunch could you not got a
bigger B basket I feel sorry for that
poor lonely bread roll in there let me
just have a look at it before you serve
it yeah oh Christ I feel like saying a
prayer so um a lunch menu and a dinner
menu baby mixed greens with sunflower
seeds dried cranberries and montet
cheese God is there anything Plain on
here Jane I think it's all good thank f
for
that is the crab fresh no it's canned
it's canned MH we'll can that one then
baby spinach salad with strawberries
goat cheese asparagus hardboiled egg and
grilled garlic shrimp strawberries and
shrimps
mhm I'll start with that please as my
appetizer
absolutely I've got to think about a
chef's perception of food when he starts
to put strawberries with fresh garlic
shrimps we see how he likes it he's a
customer customer is almost always right
did go thought we're about to receive
may the Lord not kill me with food
[Music]
poisoning
W Jesus that's
disgusting I'll wait for the next
course are you done yeah I'm I'm uh yeah
sadly the uh prawns are um Stone Cold
and undercooked okay uh your prawns are
undercooked and cold when he sent the
first dish back I knew that we were
going to have a little problem for
forp thank you okay B
petite big dirty greasy plate and like a
big overgrown ball of pubic hair Deep
Fat fried and [__] if I'm eating that
[__] that's for
sure it's tough as old
boots
God damn Raw carrot fine if you're a
[__]
rabbit how's your steak um carrots were
raw steak was tough um and that was just
a big ball of Grease um the play was
interesting especially with a
chip Gordon gave us a scathing
review thank
you it's lazy it's dirty and it's just
bad I mean really crap your carrots were
raw your state was tough and your uh Sho
string potatoes was a big balll of
Grease big ball of Grease nightmare at
Grandma's house [__]
me thank God she's dead Michelle
definitely does not respond to criticism
he likes to be the man you seem proud of
that food you seem quite yeah I like it
you like it yeah I think it's good I
mean don't take this personally yes I
thought your food was
crap tasteless bizarre your food was
long-winded boring and just you know
badly
done honestly I've never seen anyone
talk to Michelle in the way ran am talk
to him there's a waitress I don't get
complaints about the food the only
complaint I might get is uh a food's
cold Jane I'm not asking you to blow
smoke up his [__] I've just sat there
for the last hour and had one of the
worst meals I've ever eaten that's a
matter of opinion oh my God you know are
you that [__] arrogant a matter of
opinion not not being that arrogant if
you're such a passionate chef and you
are a natural cuz you're French and you
know you love cooking yes why are you
serving tin crab meat um tin crab the
main reason is because the restaurant is
quiet I buy fresh crab goes bad really
fast so I have to buy this uh this trap
I I'm trying to get inside your mind so
I can start breaking down okay to how
stupid you
are I don't think he likes
Michelle we've got a lot of work to do
in a very short period of time all I
need is not some form of French
arrogance I just need
your support and more importantly
honesty but I don't feel your I'm I'm
honest thank [__] for that thank you for
the critique what an arrogant [__] he's
so far up his own ass he can't even
[__] breathe
anymore coming up mold is festering
Gordon finds the dirty little
secrets leading to a fiery food fight
that's how you work is everything
perfect even in your kitchen don't
[__] dare start leing me and later
will this French chef be the one to push
Gord Ramsey over the edge who the [__]
are you to turn around and tell me when
you were like a pig you French
pig day two after being disappointed
with the food Gordon now inspects the
kitchen okay now Michelle's not here I
want have a good look round and just
find out what's in the fridge
is
oh oh
when was the last time that was clean oh
my God so
dirty
oh
[Music]
Jesus
[__] my goodness
me mold everywhere the food's been in
this fridge for so long even the fridge
has now started to go moldy look just
here it's like mold CED
on this thing hasn't been clean for
years look it's real
mold it's been here that long even the
bottles moldy places of health hazard
mold is festering so potentially
dangerous in terms of poisoning someone
this place can't stay open the place is
disgusting maggots oh confest the
maggots oh God
[Music]
Jesus
Christ hi Gordon Michelle how you doing
who organizes this place the cooks and
myself when was the last time we had a
really good s out
um um yesterday yesterday yes look
underneath here the amount of mold
that's growing
look it's really important that you're
honest with me every time I say
something to you all you do is smile at
me when are you going to get serious
Michelle I I I am serious well show me
some [__] seriousness then will you
cuz if you were serious you wouldn't be
having this up there what the [__] is
that that's see dark chocolate tying
and there finger marks in there where
someone's gone in with their hands
that's how you
work sometimes yeah sometimes you don't
care anymore do you is everything
perfect even in your kitchen I don't
think so it's [__] clean wait a meane
this guy with the attitude that has no
idea what's going on insults me tells me
that he doesn't have to you know his
Resturant [__] I don't want you to
come and tell me everything is awful you
hate the truth no I don't hate the truth
theuth tell me that everything is awful
you know what I can get the [__] right I
work for Thomas kill I know how the
kitchen goes I work for for let me
Thomas Keller doesn't run a kitchen like
this no it doesn't Thomas Keller's one
of the most amazing chefs in America
he'd be [__] embarrassed if you saw
this [__] uh maybe maybe not this is
extraordinary it was good for him to be
humbled Michelle was of the opinion that
hey if I want to serve dog [__] on a
plate and the customer doesn't like it
too bad the restaurant is not doing that
bad okay I make decent money how much
money have you made in 7 years how much
money have I made where in the
restaurant in 7 years what what do you
mean how much money have you made in 7
years ah sorry it's a big question you
need to make it smaller how much profit
have you made in one
year you're hiding from me m no not
really but you don't want my help I yeah
I want your help I want your help but
you know I want good help don't [__]
dare start lecturing me what you want me
to tell you I'm here to help the quicker
you understand that the better for all
of us right now every time I tell you
something is a man that's just [__]
ignoring everything I say I've met some
stubbor [__] in my time but you take
the
[Music]
piss for the rest of the day The Secret
Garden was busier than usual not cooking
but cleaning clean kitchen clean food
yeah I want it
spotless I think that the kitchen looked
gross it's good to see Michelle
scrubbing he's beginning to show some
skills in a
kitchen now that the cleanliness of the
kitchen is up to Gordon's standards it's
time for him to check out a full dinner
service well maybe not a full dinner
service the feeling when you walk in and
there's nothing it's kind of like a slap
in the
face good customers a little on the
stale side but customers
nonetheless what the hell kind of puny
appetizer is
that what is that Michelle this is a
canopy canopy yes Tres aren't even right
there we've been doing it for while
people love
it
me you
I will take a sweet potato bis okay I'll
get those for you thank
you can I have a potato FIS please yeah
take a couple minutes we need to cook it
the food all takes too long to cook so
when I take my order it'll be at least
25 minutes before it's on the table my
belief is you know it's nice to sit down
and enjoy yourself spend 2 three hours
in a restaurant that's the difference
between U American France people eat a
lot slower in French American fck now
God bless America
as customers continue to wait Gordon's
discovered Michelle's over complicated
dishes are taking too long to
prepare Michelle you're fascinated by
crusted items and stuffing things aren't
you a little bit of everything look at
the
menu
crusted the scallops
crusted I have the chili garlic crusted
Salmon crusted soft chicken crusted the
pork chop crusted and then the fet
that's a stuff I like good food I like
rich food I think it's great it's a
little spicy but not too spicy it's a
matter of opinion nobody likes
everything everybody
does oh dear it's going to be a long
night God this guy is [__]
unbelievable you know there's one thing
about being bad that's solvable but
being in complete denial throughout it's
extraordinary I've never met such a
[__] hard ass stubborn bullshitter in
all my
life this is going to be way
overcooked nope medium rare cooked
perfect even with few diners in the
dining room Michelle's stubbornness
continues to create problems in the
kitchen what table actually what table
is it on that fil cup that's the soup
you ordered are we picking up seven oh
my God Michelle wants to be the star of
the show I mean worry about it please I
understood Chef I could have been doing
so much more but Michelle wouldn't let
me I got you I got it I got it I got it
I got it if a chef is too good Michelle
does get a bit jealous I'm going to go
see what's happening in the dining
[Music]
room with Michelle headed towards the
dining room Sue Chef Devon takes over I
know what I'm doing I'm a machine and
I'm all over the
place and the food is finally getting
out right where there is
Michelle first time you've been here
before first time I like to go to the
customers because it's great for my
Eagle what are we drinking oh P I forgot
I think I know the guy that sells that
one Michelle does tend to talk an awful
lot I have a glass of wine withing for
me I hope it's good nothing's consistent
no one's taking anything no one's got
any passion and if one thing the French
have got is Passion here
zero after observing dinner service
Gordon has come to a
conclusion okay so let me tell you what
I have seen and witnessed all day I've
seen a man that I think is far more in
love with himself than he is with his
restaurant
okay tomorrow we start working together
no arguing clear understanding Chef to
Chef and I want to see some passion you
understand the word passion cuz I
haven't seen any of it tells me that I
don't give a [__] about people like only
about myself this is all [__] you
can do much better this is all
[__] coming up of all the specials
go Michelle chaos in the kitchen has
Gordon seeing red food is this table for
I don't have it it is quite frankly the
most disorganized restaurant how was
your
appetizer it's pathetic it's
embarrassing who the [__] are you to
turn around and tell me when you work
like like a pig you French Pig and is
the secret garden doomed to be a secret
forever day three Gordon is determined
to get through to this stubborn chef
with help from a little shock
[Music]
therapy okay new day and I'm determined
that this guy is going to finally start
listening to what I'm trying to to say
so this morning I've shut the place down
I've bought it up I'm going to make him
understand if he doesn't start changing
and listening to what I'm trying to say
that's what the end result and that's a
site no restant wants to
see how you turn up to work so
late what's going on I'm not closing
down this [__]
[__] good morning this is not funny I'm
pissed good good you've got every reason
to be pissed I'm glad you're angry
finally woken up now I've done this for
a reason just think how bad it would be
for your business to
close I don't see anything constructive
here it's a small town 10 people drove
by and guess what they're going to be
advertising on TV oh the restaurant is
not doing
well okay let's go big boy if the
restaurants were to close down I don't
know what would do that feel almost a
shame but for this restaurant to truly
turn around it starts with the menu
simple food No Frills straightforward
good flavor and getting customers coming
back once a week not once a
[Applause]
year everybody Every Time We Touch
something tonight we're going to be
tasting yes sir everything now Gordon is
going to teach Michelle some simple
money-making specials to put on the menu
okay the first is be roast chicken
roasted simple and bang out yeah nothing
fancy nice and easy there's a lot of
things just because we've been doing
them forever does not mean we've been
doing them the right way nothing too
expensive that's not difficult is it
guys trying to simplify how we work
faster cleaner and better they're the
four specials onion Graton
chunin roasted chicken and a fresh local
asparagus warm tart yes any questions is
he the great cook no I was voted by Chef
in kjo
[Music]
Valley Saturday night is the one night
that the secret garden is busy and a
perfect time to test Gordon's new
specials I've got some fantastic
specials to tell you about tuna Nishi a
warm asparagus tart a roasted chicken
it's very moist it's very good it's all
crisp and it's very
delicious we've got some customers in
under the age of 50 it's exciting what
can I get for you sir the French onion
soup the special the special the
asparagus tart oo music to my right here
please right away 43 how was everything
it was excellent so good it was the
perfect tenderness and it was perfect
size how does everything for you really
Gordon Rams is brilliant because of
responses I get off all my customers is
the food is great to you we love it
cheers over an hour into meal service
and the specials are proving to be very
popular but orders are starting to back
up in the
kitchen no no no not yet is this table
four is this table four table four what
is table four is this table I don't know
table four people were making mistakes
on which tables to run the food to this
is not right this is not right are they
communicating with you Michelle no
they're talking too much not
communicating no that's all right table
16 something else okay let me worry
about it you told me already earlier you
were going to compete and they have to
leave uh we've been here for like an
hour and a half and haven't eaten I know
I'm going to see the communication
wasn't quite there from the kitchen
there's not enough potatoes for the
special there's not enough eggs for the
special but no one's communicating we
telling me you have nothing left they're
still ordering them yeah I don't know
what happened I've got some specials to
tell you about we've got a warm
asparagus tart it's top with the mixed
greens very delicious specials they sold
out within 40 minutes being on the menu
and now Michelle's not communicating
we're ordering food and we haven't even
got it I have a nice bag start that was
ordered for the uh two I don't have
it I 86 it 20 minutes ago what else is
86 I don't know about let let me worry
about
it who's in charge of that dining room
out there uh uh chaos in the kitchen has
resulted in angry customers in the
dining room how was your appetizer I
never rece it oh you haven't received it
why not no I keep asking I'm getting all
cranky even though it's the kitchen's
fault we take the brunt of it and we
take the brunt of the anger I can only
hope that you forgive us I know that you
haven't had your entree yet customers
were pissed they were really really
pissed at send a manager send a manager
here man man
listen all I can do at this point is
give you your food I can't do anything
else for demanding that their f is and
now instead of turning a profit with
their new specials they're giving food
away yeah you know what you're going to
have to hold back 5 minutes it was just
chaos everybody
panicked I'm getting frustrated you want
to push me to the kitchen I will scream
at everybody so wait 5 minutes when I
lose my temper it's time for you to run
I can make one Chef you want to do it
let me worry about
it every you know what serve the food I
don't care serve that Michelle he was
just like glaring at me all damn day and
I didn't deserve it Jane you know what
serve your
words I don't have anymore it's a bit
demoralizing when he's like that as soon
as it's
ready okay all get out go in the dining
room take other customers it is quite
frankly the most disorganized restaurant
in America tonight pick up Jane let's go
let's go they're working out not I am
loaded over
no come here you have no guts where's
Jane I can't do it Jane's not okay it
all got blown up in our face today I
just I'm a little bit overwhelmed what
table whatever the table is outside they
were getting their asses handed to him
I'm mad cuz everyone's gotten their
entree and I haven't gotten anything
it's
tough see you know I'm going to find a
manager kitchen is
closed to me this is the lowest day of
this restaurant's
life is still ahead when customers mow
down the door when there's a whe there's
a way Michelle struggles to stay out of
the weeds I'm getting frustrated oh come
on but old habits die hard you run a
[__] hole of the kitchen and Gordon
loses it my [__] kitchen yeah is it
your [__] kitchen and cleaner you
lazy C
no I'm just so whatever Jane Jane's not
okay no no no no where is Jane to me
this is the lowest day of this
restaurant why kitchen is closed come on
out even though Gordon's new specials
got them off to a good start the dinner
service ended in disaster and Michelle
and his staff were exposed
I observed tonight and I was watching
everything waiters were picking up food
that didn't belong to them taking orders
with specials on them that we no longer
had communication Michelle was
Zero I think everybody can communicate
properly over here there was no control
Michelle this is all [__] okay my
restaurant is doing better than Miss ass
all over there do you think this is a
[__]
game let me tell you now my thing is
shut
up enough of tonight I want to move
on we will make this a
[Music]
success day four relaunch day and time
for Gordon to start implementing his
plan starting with the secret gardens
out dated Decor look
around this is like walking into Funeral
Parlor what does this do in a restaurant
look at the mess of it I think gives a
charm of the antique it's not this is
going that is going I want to get rid of
that stuff here we go Chef right behind
you there I'm opening up your eyes and
making the room more spacious I don't
like it you don't like it no
bye
[Applause]
Grandma next step Gordon's design team
moves in to bring the restaurant into
the 21st century redecorating the dining
room replacing the old-fashioned sign
and restoring the main
entrance okay good new menu unstuffy
dining room big big big night tonight
now get in here Chef Michelle with your
team and look at your new
[Music]
decor
very pretty oh my
goodness this is
gorgeous the rumor is bigger we've got
depth and we've got Clarity there's no
clutter how
beautiful Michelle First
Impressions completely
different it's not a secret garden
anymore it's a totally different
restaurant do you think the dining room
looks younger yes he does are you
worried about that uh big time I don't
want to destroy what I have I want to
improve what I have can you give me 2
minutes please with Chef Michelle the
few customers that we have I think
they're going to come in they're going
to go you know this is different I don't
like it instead of helping my business
you might hurt my business give me a
chance give me [__] chance I'm not
too crazy about the changes but let's
see what he can do what he can bring to
the restaurant with only a few hours to
the relaunch of the restaurant Gordon
unveils the most important part of his
plan the menu we'll go through it
together yeah for tonight's dinner
service gone are the crusted dishes
stuffed dishes and the garlic shrimp and
strawberry salad and in their place are
I've done the filo the Tunas the local
beet salad the pan roasted chicken
breast and then the double cut pork chop
and any questions on the menu That's
brilliant that's a really Brant
idea I was concerned with that menu
because you know I'm used to my old menu
and I'm sure people are going to ask for
it for tonight's grand reopening Gordon
has invited local celebrities and
dignitaries and one very influential
guest big big big night yes tonight is
the beginning of a new chapter in Secret
Gardens yes tonight is the night we set
the standards tonight yes if we do get
busy we do not
panic
now there's a food critic in
tonight knowing that there was the food
critic I was nervous I mean this is not
going to be Michelle this is different
what are they going to say how they
going to like it you don't know good
luck
everybody now that Gordon's plan has
been put into effect it's up to Michelle
and his staff to
execute reservation
for finally some Life In This Place
Hallelujah 7 go I was
nervous this is an important night we
have important people in the restaurant
Miss California has just turned up
Wow Mike table six only half of the
appetizers are gone it is so important
to keep our cool in the kitchen because
that's when it's difficult are you
listening Mike that's when you make the
mistakes with a sudden Rush of
customers Michelle's nerves are being
put to the test we got a a bus of 24
people that g unexpectedly um a large
bus has turned up from a local Vineyard
so it's called
[Music]
pandemonium Michelle can you make sure
they don't start panicking now when
we're right in the middle of this
crucial [__] night let's go over
there and need to get cooking now thank
you not tonight guys yes quiet in the
Kitchen
tonight if Gordon gets in my way give me
the knife I'll take care of it I promise
I'll make him
[Music]
suffer it's relaunch night at The Secret
Garden and the onslaught of new
customers is putting Michelle and his
team to the test Mike come right here
please right away this is an important
night we have food critics we have
important people in the restaurant we
can let it fall apart unexpectedly a
large bus has turned up from a local
Vineyard so it's called pandemonium a
bus of 24 people that
came it's craziness it's it's happening
Ste onion soup but on your Su
in Michelle has cleared his first hurdle
and the rush of customers has been taken
care of but the secret garden faces
another
challenge Jane have you spotted the food
critic yet any idea who she is no yeah
she's actually um she's actually on a
table of five now she joined four other
people is that table T
yes that is the one we give the biggest
sh
about a bring it here that's for the
food CRI table okay in 1
[Music]
minute take that
out
[Music]
do you have any feedback for me that
they're going to
ask yes the fish itself was very um
salty and overseason it was just
overseason thank you very much thank
you table 10 hates of food oh no no no
[__] off no it was salty and what's that
tuna tuna Michelle I don't know what
happened come on guys when some of the
food came back the tuna was over salty I
was sweating I was shivering no but
let's offer them something else instead
I did they don't want anything
else the new menu it's good but it's not
good enough we have to make it good
enough I apologize for that if I give
you uh one of my signature dish um is
that going to make you feel a little bit
better uh yeah something just to balance
the tightness you know uhhuh thank you
very much thank you for giving me
another chance you know I'll get get a
little more used to the menu it's a
brand new menu for me also not an excuse
but it's always a little harder so thank
you thank you thanks I'm pissed come on
that's his food is the one sending it
out remember D when there's a wheel
there's a way laen your menu is not
better than mine oh [__]
hell after over seasoning the tuna
Michelle is abandoning the new menu he's
now preparing to send his stuffed filet
of beef and Gordon is not happy hey come
on please H yeah no no no I can see it
on your face but I am not going to start
here and let you send [__] not tonight
no way I'm getting frustrated oh come on
Mr Big Chef shouldn't be in the kitchen
guy's not a
chef with the restaurant on the verge of
success Chef Michelle is insisting on
reverting back to his old ways and
Gordon has reached his Breaking Point
thank you very much I think it's great
you don't care anymore do you get
straight to the [__] answer no I'm
not getting no [__] I'm telling you
how it is [__] answer all right okay
all right good your menu is not better
than mine you know you're a donkey my
food been booted best chef in in V count
what yeah hold on hold on hold on hold
on let me finish let me finish put your
[__] hands up here listen to me you
run a [__] hole of a kitchen [__]
yourself okay no [__] off who the [__]
are you to turn around and tell me when
you were like a pig you French Pig yeah
you know what you lazy Pig big word full
of [__] open your eyes look around big
mouth you're not happy I'm [__] happy
you can get out go you can get out [__]
yourself you can't get out it's my
[__] kitchen yeah is it it's your
[__] kitchen and cleaner you lazy
[__]
[Music]
no it's relaunch night at The Secret
Garden and Chef Michelle is insisting on
reverting back to his old ways and
Gordon has reached his breaking point
you don't care anymore do you get
straight to the [__] answer no I'm
not getting no [__] I'm telling you
how it is [__] all right okay all
right good your menu is not better than
mine you run a [__] hole of the kitchen
you French Pig you can get out go on you
can get out [__] yourself you can get
out my [__] kchen yeah is it with
your [__] kitchen and clean it you
lazy [__]
now I've got to get some air before I do
something I really
regret I don't want him in my
kitchen the way ramsy did this
incredible diet tribe on Michelle and he
was just blown away
flabbergasted an extraordinary day today
but I've never seen anything quite as
shocking as that and that guy clearly
doesn't care about his customers his
food or his dining room just cares about
himself one selfish French
[__] where's the train
station I seriously thought about
walking away but there were other people
relying on me I had to finish the
job after cool pulling off Gordon
decides to return to prevent the old
menu dish from leaving the kitchen okay
yes hey I don't want to look at you in a
month's time and say you got screwed
slammed food CRI I just want everything
to be [__] perfect I agree and you
want that to be as well yes yes every
table is a VIP table yes yes Jane can we
get rid of that food please finally yeah
for the fifth
time good Michelle Please don't panic no
I Jane no one's panicking yes no yeah
please keep it together Up Up and Away
let's go yeah that's for the VIP table
that's for the food critics
table finally the food critic was given
a proper dish from the new
[Music]
menu
beautiful compliments to the chef food
is
delicious
CH even though the food critic was was
happy with the dish from the new menu
Michelle was still not convinced you
going to go out there and see them I'm
going to go to every every table when I
go to the customers they my real
critics let's see what people think
about Gordon's new menu oh it's
fantastic and the salmon is the best
I've ever had really was everything
you're liking this evening exell thank
how do you like the new dining room it's
beautiful when I asked the customers
they said they love it the food was
exquisite
Del now I'm wondering what I do wrong
how was the people when they left um
everyone loved it everyone not a angry
face okay but I want to make sure that
not angry doesn't mean they loved it I
want to make sure that they left and
they say everything was
great the people that I ask say all
wonderful thank you but if Michelle
needed a little more convincing the
answer was in the cash register you know
for 60 customers we need $50 per person
so we need a little bit more than $3,000
of Revenue this is great it was great to
have the
business after an evening of ups and
downs the relaunch was a success but
there is still one question left
unanswered did Gordon truly get through
to Michelle it is difficult to do
changes and maybe not for everybody but
for me I'm like so
wrong are you just saying that no no I
mean it I mean it the customers love the
changes I like the way the food came out
how it was clean and we profit I think
it's exciting I I I know how stubborn
you are and it's not the first time in
my career I've come across someone as
stubborn as you however tonight was much
better than the other nights you put
your first foot on the ladder mhm now
you got to keep on climbing yes when I'm
wrong I'm wrong well done now that you
know don't stop I
W with Gordon's Help The Secret Garden
was functioning as a restaurant should
and as the week progressed changes
clearly began to take hold if we all
spend half an hour cleaning this kitchen
becomes spotless Michelle is committed
to Kitchen hygiene he also promoted Jane
to manager I think she need the keys of
the restaurant with the manager title
tonight Jen is the
manager now I'm the manager I am the
[__] of the place Gordon's plan was a
success and now the secret garden is no
longer a kitchen nightmare and more
importantly customer are leaving happy
I'm feeling the love
cheers you really do have something
special please do not screw it up the
restaurant has improved immensely Ramsay
succeeded dude thanks
manager if we can't be successful now
then we're all idiots thank you much
well done it was very sad to see Gordon
leaves really helped us I think we are
at the beginning of a very very
successful year no regrets thank you no
regret promise promise still hate me oh
yes I do my heart was a very stressful
few days but I think we all survived I
think it's all for the better the secret
is
out Michelle finally learned the
cardinal rule of being a restaurant you
serve your customers not
yourself tonight on Kitchen Nightmares
Gordon heads for an Italian restaurant
that's headed for disaster why did you
decide to become a chef owner if you
haven't got a clue how to run a business
but you couldn't tell that by watching
the staff give me a break is compana a
business good afternoon comp or a high
school cooking class it's like a big
Roma room back there the owner is the
Big Man on Campus people love my food
you're seriously in denial and the
employees you seem to be here for the
party compan is like high schools
everybody like really gets along I feel
like I'm in the middle of a rehearsal
for friends I be so sexy when you make a
chicken it takes forever for the food to
get out of the kitchen I need your
specials now that [__] never went out
on top of that there's not only fighting
in the restaurant Strang there's
fighting in the parking lot why did you
keep eating if it was that bad and
because the enormous portions are
ensuring no one leaves without a party
favor even the dog's got a serving there
there's a bone FR as well the food costs
are out of control I could go in there
and just give you $500 of waste but now
the part's over you have to cut these
portions down if Gordon can't get this
cast of Friends to grow up take it
serious I will run it like a boss this
restaurant's going to be grounded for
life I felt like I was eating around
girl tonight on Kitchen Nightmares this
is not part of time this is serious time
we're doing it okay all right let's
go
fairon New Jersey a predominantly
Italian Community about 20 minutes from
New York City for years compa was a
successful business but since Joe
cerniglia took ownership 18 months ago
the business has dramatically declined
and it's only a few months away from
closing good afternoon comp I didn't go
to culinary school what's this chicken
for we don't have recipes we don't use
measuring cups or spoons cuz I'm the
best we are waiting on the pecans
there's no pecans huh there's no pcons
it said pine nuts oh we have a lot of
fun
here sometimes I guess a bad thing cuz
we don't take everything too seriously
sometimes Nut Job [__] you I'm not a nut
job the kitchen's always playing
practical jokes on each other why would
you stop blocking him in the
walking sorry Mom
it's like a big Romper Room back there a
great we're all like little kids we're
all very silly now what I'm still a kid
I still have a tongue ring I still have
a tattoo and I don't really plan on
changing the way I think anytime soon I
am serious but I'm going to have fun
with it while I'm you know in the
process gentle work compani definitely
has its it's it's share problems big
problems oh [__] our oven is broken
completely broken these are not working
ovens so they've now become storage for
us we have two walk-ins the handles are
broke first this latch broke so this
door just kind of swings open it doesn't
lock shut the men back there they should
be able to fix it I think I'm a pretty
Democratic boss open your freezer get me
some
ponchetta Joe gets very easily flustered
and frustrated which a lot of times
winds up making everybody break down F
you got the broccoli Rob where's the
broccol Rob I don't have brocc I asked
you if you had broccol Rob he said yes
come on it took long enough it's
frustrating here because food needs come
out quicker that [__] should have been
done last
night I worry about Joe I worry about
stress level I worry about Melissa I
worry about the boys it is not easy I'm
financially in trouble the debt of the
restaurant alone is overwhelming my
personal debt wife kids mortgage that's
a lot of debt you put everything into
one
Venture it takes a a lot of Courage you
know I owe my purveyors about $8,000
right now in Cold Hard Cash I'll get
something out to you on um Monday you're
better some of the purveyors will show
up and ask for a check but I don't know
if it's the economy or what I can't see
us going on another year and and that's
a really scary thought and I'm going to
do everything in my power to avoid
that
I'm looking for a restaurant an Italian
restaurant on the main strip here
comp thank you
Campa hardly a uh perfect location for a
restaurant on a strip mall but let's be
honest it's a food at counts and I've
heard they've got problems
huh oh dear hello hey are we one uh oh
yes today I'm on my own yes follow me
fact most times I'm always on my own how
are you today good how you doing well
thank you you're welcome love thank you
you're
welcome Mr Ramsey how are you Ma I'm Joe
slia good to see you welcome to New
Jersey is this uh are you always
pointing or is that just I point a lot I
use my hands you know I'm Southern
Italian so there's a lot of
that all right that's the way I am it's
the way I operate I don't know what he
was looking at okay what would you like
today uh may I start please I'll try the
bord toini yes and then um I'll try the
r okay finish with with pistachio and
cranberry crusted breast of chicken
thank you thank you you're welcome ready
to go Joseph clam white torini soup I
mean I was smiling but my heart was
racing backing that up with a torini
soup but I got torini soup work and I
got my half RAV work and I got it all
you my friend
relax what sounds like a very very busy
kitchen back there I'm so e hungry oh so
I didn't eat anything on [__] hry you're
hungry I'm hungry I'm hungry yeah what
is going on in
there
God the brow
[Music]
relax I thought you gone
home no no I was waiting for your
soup I hope go didn't satisfied if he's
not I'm sure he's going to let us
no you're just Bland and tasteless that
one was definitely not worth the wait
how is everything are they made here
these or they bought in they're filled
with v oh no I know it's trust I know
what it was that wasn't the question I
asked they're homemade yes they bought
in from a place that makes them homemade
thank you is it popular yeah um somewhat
I love the way you skip over it are they
popular not too many people order it as
much no so no thank good night you're
welcome I think Gordon is going to drive
me crazy by the end of it all it's going
to drive us all crazy homemade means
made on site end the story cut the
crap F they
up all right let's take them
[Music]
out thank you you're welcome so this is
the grilled sausage in there yes yes yes
lovely garlic everywhere big big big
chunks of it everywhere hey yeah yeah
you would want to go back to the office
with that breath would you Gordon found
that we had too much garlic in our sauce
Jesus I tend to like garlic so I never
really noticed it okay thank you okay
you're welcome thank you very much I
would like a toothbrush now please you
want to know it's too much garlic son
[__] I think it was just fine
personally for me if I was eating that I
wouldn't have a problem with
[Music]
it what my
go here you
go chicken what is that on top there
real zucchini okay holy mackerel looks
like your bison's
tongue it's dry it's sweet and
it's go dear he didn't like the chicken
he didn't like the sauce didn't like the
crust thought it was well done hated
[Music]
it one thing that fascinated me
throughout the whole lunch all I could
hear was laughing and joking and lots of
screaming coming out of the kitchen um I
was pissed off waiting you don't expect
to hear all that laughing and giggling
when you stand there waiting on all your
food the toralo ve was just Bland and
watery then my uh grilled sausage I've
never seen so much garlic in addition
all my life Gordon called me out of my
food I'm not [__] happy Italian food
is about rusticness phenomenal
ingredients and something that's relaxed
and casual but in a delicious way and I
just it you know somewhat boring to be
honest you'll see us rock it
out my food I think is is pure and
honest and good I think it was a mistake
that I did
this
man up next why did you decide to become
a chef owner if you haven't got a clue
how to run a business Gordon serves up
the truth I've never seen such humongous
portions you would need that would can
Joe swallow it no all right you know
what why are we making a public issue
with this now there's customers here
there's customers here I'd rather have
this conversation downstairs how about
that would you want to find and when the
staff monkeys
around you Gordon Goes Bananas right
who's going home that's coming up on
Kitchen
Nightmares day two and with this
restaurant in financial hell Gordon
knows that he needs to increase business
but he also needs to find ways to cut
costs I've been thinking about this
overnight and what's bugging me now is
what's he wasting in these fridges
that's my concern now this must be a
pain in the
ass the minute a muscle opens they're no
longer fresh they're gone that's
dangerous that's it's dead muscle's dead
this menu is far too big for his own
good I don't understand what's going
through his mind to have this fridge
stock with all these ingredients and no
customers to cook for look bag after bag
after bag there's nearly 2 months worth
of chopped garlic there this is where
his $80,000 debt is in all this
ingredients this fre is stopped now like
a restaurant that would be fully booked
for 3 4 weeks in advance and we haven't
got those customers so why the [__] have
we got all this ingredient stupid
absolutely crazy with a young head chef
and an inexperienced owner Gordon
decides it's time for restaurant
management 101 you're in charge of the
purchasing yeah those fridges are
stocked up for a a busy restaurant we
haven't got money to waste there's
endless ingredients in there that are
not being used properly everything we
buy is costing money I can point fingers
in every direction for the the Walkins
being crowded and it's a catch22 cuz we
run out of something Joe throws a fit
when was the last time you had a budget
per week is
$4,200 I don't think we're scrutinizing
what we're purchasing I could go in
there and just give you $500 of waste I
saw that [__] walking in a completely
different light I went holy
[__] hopefully Gordon's economics lesson
has sunk in now it's time to see how
this jovial Bunch handles a dinner
service which given the lack of
customers shouldn't be that difficult
you're going to get in
trouble even so Gordon has to make sure
these kids stay
focused okay right you you understand
what's going on this is not party time
this is serious time nothing to do with
friends take it [__] serious will run
it like a boss let's go but all habits
die hard this
me comp is like high schal cuz it's like
really close nit social environments
everybody like really gets along yes yes
yes yes yes yes I'm proba like the
biggest flirt here we just all feel very
comfortable around each other while
compa restaurant is really more like ca
High Gordon wants Joe to start treating
it more like a business and less like a
party 2 seconds every everybody yes here
we go right uh 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
11 members of Staff staff cost right
who's going
[Music]
home that was it was pretty blatant in
uh it's a big move real big move Gordon
definitely means business business sorry
guys thanks for coming but thanks but no
thanks it's a little scary when Gordon
all of a sudden eyeballs je who's going
home
[Music]
trucks see you buddy play
guitar good take care buddy get yourself
a
haircut next I need three on the floor
three waiters on the floor let's go
who's
next Katie Katie thanks but no thanks
any questions I cut a few people they
were clearly upset you know Katie was
definitely upset Katie no get out of my
[__]
I had to you know I had to make a tough
call tonight and I really wanted to have
people tonight that were you know on
their game I'm good enough when he needs
me when his ass is on the line but not
for that I came in tonight and cancel
dinner plans to all my friends
cuz good luck let's
go with the staff now trimmed down play
time is over good evening Madam how are
you good to see you and it's time to
focus on the customer
one order or two I have the muscles two
so two orders Okay order in please
appetizers walking in salad Roto muscles
Mozel Entre are pork retto Cod and a
chicken how get the chicken
also come on as orders hit the kitchen
the staff is quickly overwhelmed and
everything is moving at a snail's pace
how many of these did you sell guys come
on don't lose it look I I had some Penta
wedges they went back there and they and
they're lost they're right here they're
not me
[__]
man excuse me is there any possible way
we can get um shrimp cocktail that's
what K is known for is waiting 3 hours
for your food are you guys okay we're
getting restless yeah everyone's hungry
it's been taking a little time for the
appti
starving and not surprisingly problems
in the kitchen have customers totally
frustrated I want to drink wine and wine
and wine and wine and wine cheers guys
cheers
Vinnie's authentic pizza yeah how you
doing um I'd like to place some order
for a pizza where the [__] is 13 that
[__] never went out oh come on give
it was nuts was crazy I need that rotto
Joe what one more no it's on your table
Joe Joe it's on your [__] table my
man holy [__] come on were you guys
sitting here for a while before anybody
came to you it's 30 minutes for a salad
I have people pointing at me and they're
going like this and I don't understand I
can't tell them you know how hard it is
to put lettuce in a bowl
with some dressing come on guys come on
come on come on we're getting backed up
now I'm waiting on a Cod come on table
three show me that c I'm trying to fix
it you pass it to be broken and when the
food finally arrives at the tables it's
met with mediocre reviews the worst
thing you can do with fish is over F
yeah this is grade D dog food just just
stop stop stop stop stop stop Joe yes
guys I'm sorry but I'm not [__]
serving that yeah and I'm not serving
that so will you please stop what you're
doing and do something about it guys
another observation by Gordon of this
restaurant's inefficiency is its portion
size almost every customer leaves with a
doggy
bag unbelievable right and huge portions
mean unnecessary inflated food
costs
really I've made the decision bite the
Bol on the portion sizes I think that's
what the people like what uh what's
wrong with it nothing is wrong with it
it's going to take it away they're
taking it away takes me to oh my God
even the [__] dogs got a serving
there there's the bone FR him as
well losing business big time as comp's
customers leave with their massive
leftovers Gordon knows it's not just the
food they're taking but Joe's profits as
well sit down sit down did you want all
this food now do you have friends with
you yeah and right now you're my guest
okay yeah let me just point two or three
things out this is two appetizers two
Entre mix salad and your Bretta I'm
trying to show you what you give your
customers every day lunch and dinner
I've never seen such [__] humongous
portions every customer that left here
this evening took food to go it's what
the customers are used to the customers
love this they like the big portions for
a man that's [__] financially in the
[__] and thrown money lit down the drain
for every dish you put in here and then
on top of that you can't even [__]
grill a piece of Bretta there see that
bit there you wouldn't need that would
you
huh no talk to me no you getting upset
now yeah I'm getting real upset thank
[__] for that hopefully I'll get through
to you now you're throwing thousands of
dollars down the drain why did you
decide to go into business if you
haven't got a clue how to run a
business all right you know what why are
we making a [__] public issue with
this now this customers here this
customer here I'd rather have this
conversation downstairs how about that
are you scared again am I scared you're
embarrassing me in front of my
[Music]
customers behind every restaurant is a
family and when the restaurant's in
trouble it's a family that suffers so uh
I want to get to Joe's wife Melissa and
just actually find out what's really
going on in Joe's
mind hi are you Mela how are you you
like good to see you too how you well
boys home from school hi they are yeah
how you doing my man first name Evan
Evan nice to see you girlfriend's
name at this a nice house oh thank you
how long have you been here uh 4 years
four years lovely so um three boys three
boys big responsibility yep yeah lot of
pressure on Joe's shoulders um how do
you think he's doing he's very power
positive and you know it's his dream and
I know he's giving it his all to you
know try and succeed but you know it's
not just all about being passionate in
the kitchen that's what I'm trying to
tell him and whilst I love his
enthusiasm around the food it's a
business it's not just the food I agree
with you 100% I do and I don't know I
mean so I'm glad you're here I mean I
think he needs to see the black and
white more hardest thing for me is that
people like us put everything on the
line for a dream MH and I just want to
see him have a
time you know to
succeed please don't get
upset I don't want you to get upset
please told him all these things that
you told him before he needs to know the
Jeopardy like as of this month alone
like I can't pay my bills here like
Joy's months behind on us being paid MH
I mean it's as bad as it probably gets
you know if this restaurant
fails we would lose everything I mean
I'll lose my house but this business can
turned around and I pointed out two or
three things yes it can yes it
definitely can so you're going to help
yes
now having given Melissa his word Gordon
now knows that to turn this business
around he must spend time in the kitchen
retraining the chefs from food prep yep
to presentation I've watched the way we
serve food here no one really gives any
[__] care and attention to a little
bit of presentation I know it's rustic
but at least make sure that we got a
little bit of pride in what we're doing
that looks like a [__] you can do
better having Gordon Ramsey in the
kitchen that was pretty cool he's on top
of his game man that's why he is where
he is just keep it flat yeah it's just
just breaking
apart have so much water in it yeah but
you always salt it like you're doing
like a Brad or like a Maru you salt it
so it gets nice and firm put it down use
one sharp cookie I can tell you that
much basically he's teaching us that we
have to step up okay chicken cut off the
drum and the the thigh and then sit them
on top of one another so it just looks a
little bit neater yeah now that Gordon
has given Joe and the chef several
pointers it's time for Gordon to
introduce a signature dish they can
handle meatballs Why Can't This
restaurant become famous for a meatball
I go to my restaurant in Sly of
Meatballs that's all I want just give me
meatballs Gordon showed us meatballs I
think it's a great idea let's go little
bit of cheese on there good I think us
being known for the meatballs isn't so
bad because um usually known for uh for
never really coming out
ever with the aid of Gordon's recipe Joe
and his staff are now armed withstanding
meatballs now it's time to conquer New
Jersey meatballs oh look at
this best
meatballs a new jerseys yes best
meatballs okay Joe give out the
t-shirts out came the meatballs and and
and the flashy t-shirts and the and we
pretty much shout the message loud and
clear comp's got the best meatballs in
New Jersey give these meatballs away and
get the reputation out there on the
street yes get them M out folks we got
the best meatballs
around stop on in and have some dinner
one of these days if we can start
getting people into our restaurant for
our meatballs it's just a great step in
the right direction let me put some hot
sauce on there this is so much fun
that's wonderful we got some meatball
fans you're ding there we are
everyone loved the meatballs does that
dog like meatballs I think he does look
at him he he loves it compan your
restaurant comine your restaurant we
gave out some food we spread the b word
about the restaurant we had some fun you
know you want them just don't get hit by
a car for him the best meatballs in New
Jersey now that the meatball marketing
has spread the word about compana it's
time for Gordon to have a serious
one-on-one talk with Joe we bought it 18
months ago over a period of 18 months
how much have you lost yeah I'd say
about 120,000 [__] I'm in trouble how
serious is this restaurant for you it's
it's everything to me you think you
could continue like this for what 6 more
months about that yeah I think that's
pushing it your business is about to
[__] swim down the Hudson I heard
Gordon's Point loud and clear I mean
this is it this is this is this is
crunch time stand
strong don't take it personally just
take it seriously tomorrow is the
biggest
day coming up it's comp's reopening and
everyone is feeling the pressure I need
your specials now she said the steak was
6 half Gordon has some quiet time with
an unruly customer talking out your R
and while some people welcome the
changes to the menu absolutely
unbelievable others aren't so sure I
felt like I was eating R go it's a night
filled with emotions why did you keep
eating if it was that fad and a dinner
service you don't want to miss next on
Kitchen
Nightmares it's day four and time for
comp's relaunch Gordon's design team has
come up with a contemporary New Look to
match the new direction of the
restaurant I've created a new look for
the new Capa let's
go
lovely how cool is that is that nice ho
crap awesome oh how cute is that oh my
god oh it's unbelievable I was just
absolutely Blown Away absolutely blown
away and it was just High time for it to
be changed now you can really see it's a
restaurant all the lights are on all the
canopy's lit just looks really inviting
now it's awesome we definitely needed
this it looks like a proper Resturant
thank you definely so much Melissa happy
yes Gord has created so many great new
things here like the sign and everything
shows that he's making it
better so nice H let's get inside yes
let's do it the one thing you're not
going to smell when we get in here is
garlic
let's I opened those doors and it was
just alive the restaurant was alive the
whole place just metamorphosized with
some great simple little changes the
dining room looks unbelievable those
candles are going to be awesome at night
yes is it nice kind of place I just want
to hang out I am a little overwhelmed
right now I have really no words to say
you know it's a little shocked the
lights of dim music is on
right let's clut them this place is
lovely you guys have transformed my
restaurant follow me through to the
kitchen let's Jesus oh no Joe stressed
out a lot so when you see him smile like
that it makes you feel good come oh my
God this is so freaking cool launch the
new menu a new stove yes I'm overwhelmed
with this big beautiful stove you know
boys with toys this is my new toy right
here baby oh my God
Jean almost had tears in his eyes big
mean Jean I don't have to light the
pilots every time I turn it on and it's
just phenomenal
happy I'm just so happy to see him
getting a little help he deserves to
succeed and I just I know he's going
to Gordon also provided smaller plates
to coincide with the smaller portions oh
my God any plates they're smaller it out
plates were just way too big and
therefore we had to use a lot more food
to fill them up and that's all also
losing money right there wow man I I am
speechless you guys have done so much
for us in one day I know what to
[Music]
say next step in getting ready for the
big night Gordon sits down with the
young chefs to introduce a brand new
menu the secret um of the menu is to
keep it tight we have to start making
money I had some initial concern about
what my customers to think about coming
in and not seeing my big diverse menu
this menu includes the new pasta and
rotto section the Kini um something you
expect to see in any you know nice
restaurant but do it with a little bit
more varied you know pesto tomato
Alfredo I like the new menu a lot
Gordon's uh that's he's one sharp
[__] cookie I can tell you that much
um the BRAC pork that's a great dish the
creamy plenter coats the pork the flavor
is lovely and then the bka you know a
really nice grilled New York strip steak
with roasted potatoes and spinach
beautifully done the meatballs we've
done it in both appetizer and entree as
well we've now focused on our meatball
as becoming a bit of a Hallmark if
people start bitching the meatball is
are going to come out of the kitchen and
hopefully that'll appease them while
they're waiting the meat go get it R the
meatball I really like the new menu and
the way we're doing it and the concept
of having a smaller menu everything was
good Ste is
awesome an hour before the opening
Gordon comes up with a clever way to
motivate the Young weight staff I've
devised a plan the same plan I have with
my waiters and waitresses that every
item on this menu will be sold
every item here we go come with me let's
go here is the menu okay and on these
boards are your names each and every one
of you yeah have got to sell every item
on this list the first person finishes a
complete menu you shout Bingo and there
you've got $100 incentive the whole idea
of having a contest to motivate servers
I think it's a great idea
$100 to sell the whole
menu I have a six o00 booking for table
five perfect ready I'm so F right we got
to talk together tonight we got to work
as a team I'm going to step up as much
as I can and hopefully it works out
you're Expediting you're delegating
everybody out the kitchen right I'm
excited for tonight's dinner service I
think everyone's going to be on a good
positive note tonight look at that oven
unbelievable it's unbelievable it's Do
or Die For Us failure is not an option
I'm not going to let Gordon down I have
to show them that we can do this it's
got to
[Music]
happen tonight is the reopening of
compana D could you open the doors
please and Gordon Ramsay's new menu has
packed the restaurant welcome to compa
welcome to
comp this is the night Joe has been
waiting for but if it doesn't go well it
could destroy his dream this is a big
night for us the pressure's on Jean
first I was here yes do it guys good
night I I want Gordon to leave on a high
note I want to be able to pull this off
Joseph write it down spread the word
okay we're going to do a red snapper in
CIO I'll be right back in just a moment
take your orders so you can look over
the menu are you guys ready to order
your Entre what do you have I'm try the
and spaghetti on your recommendation
sure I'll have the ravioli ravioli
perfect thank you guys listen everything
sells together tonight if somebody says
their food's ready in 2 minutes it's 2
minutes the first orders are in and
Gordon waiter competition is underway
you're off meb's gone what else chicken
chicken chicken I just got a tent top
I'm about to sell like half of it okay
go girl go the first customers of the
night are responding well to the new
menu you have to taste this this is this
is absolutely unbelievable best F ever
hadu is amazing but even good food can't
impress everybody
[Music]
terrible I can better that's horrible
absolutely hor ter are you kidding or no
I'm not oh you're serious that I went
even feat to my
dog
Terri everyone at the table doesn't like
any of their food what should I do did I
comp everything or here I am now in this
Pinnacle moment and I start hearing the
complaints it was almost too bad to be
true I need you need to get feedback
from me okay why didn't you like it she
said steak was too
tough which doesn't look tough to
me after Gordon sees nothing is wrong
with the food he decides it's time to
stick up for his young chefs trying to
say
swee why don't you just take a seat and
just sit down and try to enjoy a cup of
coffee how can you enjoy something that
when you come my husband is starving
number say back okay my steak was tough
okay good but Madam unfortunately you're
talking out your rear oh am I your mouth
care but you're just walking around
looking for trouble why don't you just
sit down stop trying to cause
trouble there we
go ladies welcome good evening Hi how
are you so sorry about the old
bag an hour into dinner service and menu
Bingo is achieving its goal of customers
ordering a wide variety of items on the
menu want to see who's winning Jo said 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 n I'm a second place I'm
back with now the pressure of the big KN
is taking its toll on Joe there's too
much saffron on that there's too much a
Jesus Christ when anything goes wrong
the Cod looks like [__] like absolute
[__] Joe gets in that really stressed
out panicky mode why is that taking a
long time Joe I worry about Joe I worry
about stress level huh why is that
taking a long time uh because those
chickens just got cooked are you [__]
serious I need salt I'm very reactionary
I get stressed out for like 5 minutes
but you know what I just try to find
that comfort zone I could tune things
out if I want to Jean I'm leaving you
guys be now I got to run out there okay
looking for a little relief from the
intensity of the kitchen Joe takes a
stroll into the dining room hey how's it
going good how are you I'll see you in a
bit man okay we got we got all life to
talk how's it going guys you guys have a
horrible habit of dropping every [__]
table in the restaurant at the same [__]
time is CH good talking to you guys he's
Houdini he's not around and you have to
pick up the slide Jean yeah it's getting
crazy out there now we got to step up
again yes all right guys come on with
Jean left alone in the kitchen one
muscles left orders are backed up and
customers are now experiencing what
compa used to be known for slow service
we've been here for 40 minutes and I
haven't eaten yet we just had to do a
lot of things differently tonight we've
been here since 7:00 everything would
just took a while to come out it's
insane back there but uh no it's coming
right right out I'm so busy right now I
can't even breathe right now everyone's
waiting for 2 hours for their food it
really 9:00 it's 2 hours already how
long does it take to make spaghetti I'm
having lettuce they don't understand
what's taking so long I mean but at
least if some would came over on
the I have a table of like eight people
they're upset they want to speak to a
manager dropping table 20 hold on hold
on everybody shut up this is a [__]
clust
F guys what's going
on a little I don't know what to say I
don't I was out at the table they had a
complaint they waited a long time uh
they weren't happy with the food I'm
sorry about what happened I'm sorry
that's not exactly all right let me I I
got I got to run I got to run back there
I'm sorry but no I do I do I guess you
really
do at that point you know I really
didn't want to be in that position and I
was really just trying to back away from
the
table the [__] pasta's going in while
Jean puts out fires in the kitchen the
angry customer is making her way to the
front of the restaurant and is now
complaining in front of Joe's mom she's
outy a complainant to these people is
Joe I don't know I'm very disappointed
been here many many times I felt like I
was eating
Ragu I really did yeah that one out
there was saying the foods like Ragu
she's out there I had the fish it was
great well somebody else had the fish
and it tasted like pwn water I'm
listening to this witch I want Strang
over I was so aggravated I was so upset
you know that somebody would do that to
my son while Joe could not diffuse the
situation with the unhappy customer
shockingly a less than sober but
satisfied customer comes to the defense
of
comp why did you keep eating why did you
keep eating if it was that bad what's
her problem if it was that bad you the
[__] Liars you just bought everything
for free you greedy [__] [__] oh my
God in heaven you people are meal go
have another bottle of a wine [__]
alcoholic [__] have another bottle of
wine [__] L who is
that why did you keep eating if it was
that b what's her problem if it was that
bad cuz you're the [__] Liars you
just bought everything for free you
greedy [__] [__] oh my God have you
people are mental go have another bottle
of a wine you [__] alcoholic [__]
[__] smoking you dirty Italian honey
can I [__] cut it can I just be alone
have another bottle of light [__] low
light who is that
person a police car on neighborhood
Patrol extinguishes the fiery argument
outside the restaurant okay J just uh
two seconds please let's go back in the
kitchen Gordon asks to talk to Joe
privately to get him focused and back on
track when you're pissed straight to the
point over done with I'm move move on
you understand don't hide behind there
step out into the dining room two or
three times in with the customers 30
seconds back out if anyone's disgruntled
put an end to it immediately don't stand
there bargaining with them yeah just and
back in but I I want to see you run it
yeah yeah I have to get series it takes
me a long [__] time to get something
through my thick skull but when it when
it does happen I'm steadfast I was going
to do it I believed in it and when I
believe in something I [__] do it
here we go here we go come on let's
these let's sell these you got spinach I
want to make sure that we're nice and
vibrant yes right now two steaks two vs
and a chicken okay every steak that
comes in now write skirts so we can tell
the difference okay listen and now that
Joe has taken his mission seriously it
rubs off on his staff who are now
working professionally and efficiently
skirt Ste spread the word okay make it a
good thing it's something
special J Ramin now I think Joe has
motivation to do what he can to make it
better and he just inspired us all to I
think just work work as a team
communicate um be a little more serious
they're catching you up now come on come
on come on the honey and the
strawberries so good yep there goes one
more okay I'm going to start the
mozzarella over here you've only got two
left yes I do
yeah
yes told you a bottle of wine or a 100
in front of you I better have the hund
$100 I won tonight just for playing
bingo but you know I busted my butt and
I sold everything I needed to sell I
knew I was going to win I knew it server
Bingo was definitely fun the whole idea
of having a contest to motivate servers
I think it's a great idea Ariana I just
won server Bingo was a really novel idea
and it worked we were all talking about
afterwards we want to keep doing that we
like the contest that was fun can you
guys handle these pickups now there's
not much more coming in really nothing
was going to stop me Gord really forced
the issue on me and I really believed at
that point that that these changes were
good perfect Joe how somebody follow
with it okay Joe was definitely more
focused especially behind the line there
was no practical jokes going on really
really enjoyed the food it was
great cuz we care I was making sure that
everybody was on top of their game and
if they weren't I I'd be there to help
them out you're doing an awesome job I'm
so proud of you I'm proud of you too get
to
work good night have a nice weekend
now that the last tables have been
served Gordon gathers the team together
the difference in tonight's service as
opposed to last night service was night
and day and we done double the amount of
people tonight that we did last night
203 were in for dinner we were
consistent the food was good the service
was good and everybody had an appetizer
an on train dessert what would be the
take come what midnight say we took in
about $7,500 we made3 three times what
we made last night I don't think I've
ever made the money um that that I made
tonight tonight was a really successful
night really
was hey
hey there's no words no words to tell
you how I feel about what Gordon's done
for Joey I am thrilled to death for him
and let me tell you what I saw you
tonight showed me that yes you were a
head chef Don't
Stop Don't Stop
I think there's good things in our
future I mean we're going to dig our
heels in and we got a good groundwork
now after Gordon came in
[Music]
here in the days that followed customers
were thrilled with the new menu this is
so good it was delicious what about the
dessert is it with sensible portions
less waste in the fridge and more
customers profits increase dramatically
you know I'm happy I like the food
that's going out the window happy
customers great food food good bottom
line Joe finally started behaving like a
boss and not everyone's friend you're
going to sell two chickens for me okay
successfully taking control of both the
front of the house pleasure to meet you
guys and the kitchen okay good we're
going to sell two steaks and a chicken
somebody Clos that door food's going
cold and now compa is known for its
quality rather than its quantity with
the staff now ready to run a restaurant
properly there was one more thing Gordon
wanted to take care of before he said
goodbye
the food looked great on there yes we're
not going back to stupid big steering
wheels that's what we're serving look at
them aren't they
horrible let's
go do one you give me say goodbye to
them say goodbye say goodbye I tell you
breaking those plates was just like you
know the weight you know coming off my
[Music]
shoulders
when Gordon broke the plates we were
like rock on that's [__] awesome
goodbye to the big place hello profits
one two 3
go John you
happy the breaking of the plates how
symbolic was that wasn't it awesome out
with the old and you know into the new
thank you well done done well done well
done done done well done what a big boy
yes huh you know you hate to see him go
but it was a good time we got to break
all the [__] plates he uh he was
proud of us I think right oh [__] thank
you thank you so much I think that comp
is going to be everything that Joey
wants it to be good on guys first day I
met Gordon I couldn't wait until that
guy said goodbye but once I got Beyond
My Pride being hurt my ego being hurt
and started listening to what he had to
say he was like a true mentor to me
customers have to come back for the good
food not the portion size remember that
yes good luck thanks you're [__]
meatball H good luck take care all right
hey don't stop I
won't during the Capa gang were a fun
group to hang out with but the lack of
discipline was killing the business it
feels like they've changed I only hope
it
[Music]
continues